taking back it's either 100 live on a
Sunday or a percentage is 10,000 for a
video conference at 11:30 in the morning
on a Sunday pass
you got your prospectus for Jason's
first big shout out to you brother
doing a great job you tag yourself in
here right now they need to know you're
part of the fam just did a hacking
session you're gonna have to bounce
around that because there's a lot of IP
but there might be one or two things
when you start seeing creative that's
contextual to psycho demographics
against proxies that are business right
that's right
that was for effect good [ __ ] I like
where you going man if I wasn't here
after that nobody now going to a
doctor's appointment then I'm flying to
Alabama for the Senior Bowl Vayner
Sports is kicking off going down there
see our guy Tyree Jackson quarterback
from the University of Buffalo that
we're excited about big shout out to AJ
and rest of the team super excited about
Atlanta next week Super Bowl our Super
Bowl party or meet-and-greet let's link
that up as well what can I drop here
knowing that this you're leaving after
this right I'm gonna stick around
okay good
so either now or my for the car ride
what can I do in two or three minute
rant that will bring the most value to
everybody look guys look I guess like
synthesizing the last you know three
years this is an inside your head game
like at some point eventually a piece of
content I make is gonna breakthrough
maybe it's this one maybe at this moment
like that the outside voice is the
outside structure like these are forces
that you don't have control over so
dwelling about your mom or your dad or
your boss or the economy or somebody
left a comment it's just not gonna work
it's just not this is an insular game
the quieter to gives in your head and if
you get the framework and I'm and I'm
very like up here right mentality like
mindset and then I'm very tactical right
like if you really break me down it down
watching me do what I do what I do not
what I say kind of thing like watch what
I do not what I'm saying even though
they align it's like first look if
you're perfect and Instagram ads and
influence your ads and make the best
shoes and like all these things like by
the way if the shoes come in you gonna
have to blur amount blow them out again
blur you know like you're gonna have to
understand that unless this is right if
you're perfect and execution you're
gonna lose this is why people on Wall
Street or athletes or celebrities crush
to make money they get Fame but then
they burn out they die they go into
depression the drugs like cuz this
wasn't right so for me so much of what
I'm trying to do is get you not to keep
up with the Joneses not worry about your
parents think don't worry don't think
that money brings you happiness like all
this stuff and then every time somebody
comes cynical good easy for you to say
I'm like yo you didn't know me bro when
I was 19 go hit up Rob Muse go hit up
Robbie turn it go help an arson bird
right go ahead Brandon Warnecke like go
you know people when I didn't have right
looking you're like go hit up people
when I didn't have it was optimism it
was optimism it was optimism it was
don't give a [ __ ] about what somebody
says once you go there you go fast you
do you make once you get out of your own
head you just go you go fast
when you're further in the career what
what keeps the momentum because you were
talking about it you don't know me back
then right what about now yeah you like
so many box it's so it's so easy right
like for me I don't care about the money
I care about my game the process and
like those are the happiest people
whether you are making financial success
or whether you're making forty two
thousand dollars a year being you know a
farmer and you love [ __ ] growing
pumpkins you've one life the amount of
people that make way more money than me
but hate the process are not luckier
than are not more fortunate than me
happiness has to be the ROI happiness
has to be what everybody achieves
like and and it's an evolution all three
of us in this car right now are doing
different things that we used to be
doing different things make you happy
different than ever like like I can be
unhappy tomorrow and I'll change like
happiness is what I chase I chase
happiness right like what keeps me going
is I love what I'm doing I do it for
free I would this is me playing I'm
playing I know you get it because
anybody who's creative really gets it
right starving artists are real like
that's real and I I feel far more
similar to a starving artist than I do
to like a hedge fund Wall Street gal
right because I feel like a lot of
people in that world are not everybody
but a lot of people are driven by money
I just I don't know how people don't get
it well I do I do when you don't have
something und it when somebody's super
attractive they take it for granted
right ah be you take your super
attractiveness for that you know but
like really like if you're a ten guy or
girl like you don't even understand what
it's like for people who can't get
anybody they want or or get you know
like there's so many privileges
whether you're smart whether you do math
well whether you don't have anxiety
whether you're
act and whether you have money whether
you don't have money and you love the
grind like like there's unlimited
amounts of privileges and adversities it
just comes down to perspective like I
think growing up with nothing was the
greatest thing that ever happened to me
other people still are 53 are
complaining that's why they weren't
successful they lack accountability yes
dentist or something gonna be good
you're right my lady but like and it's
funny that we're talking about a hundred
get so much in this vlog I've said in
talks and maybe you can find it for to
clip in here that was my number two that
was the only number I wanted to get two
hundred that seemed big by the way a
hundred and you're living $130,000
lifestyle sucks
forty-two and living a twenty thousand
dollar lifestyle is amazing there's no
other variables besides how much you
make anybody who runs a business knows
it's the profit at the end to me and
life the profit at the end is the
happiness radar if you're making a
hundred but you decided to move into a
neighborhood where you're keeping up
with Joneses and everybody else is more
like a two hundred family and you're
just trying to keep up versus go into a
neighborhood worth eating
and you're like big fish small but like
there's so many things do you need close
to say you're cool and like do you have
like do you feel bad when you're like
some parents are crushed when their kids
can't go to Disney World like everybody
else other parents see that as the chip
on the shoulder that the kids gonna use
like it all is perspective what keeps me
going is life like happiness is the ROI
[Music]
Brazil I don't result for you so try and
see what I can do I have another group
that's coming to the table but we have
100 grand November 8 which is a Friday
but a pretty large event it's about
13,000 can I get I mean the big issue
there is I have to be back for the Jets
game the money is not exciting but the
but the the size and the market is
exciting
you think you push them ok and I'm
willing a discount to like 135
potentially on the other one but let's
buy some time cool thanks brother talk
to you alright bye bye
you can use that whole thing that's cool
Bobby you got freaked out by that just
like Howie
you mean the under how quick I'm just
like pass I didn't make $100,000 here
when I was 31 years old a year I keep
talking about patience I didn't make
that in a year for a day for a speech
time so at 30 I started Wine Library TV
YouTube blows up at 31 I'm on Conan
O'Brien Ellen there's articles being
written about me now they're writing
that the business grew from three to
sixty million dollars in sales I'm
becoming this guy I got so many goddamn
emails from friends in high school
during that period when I was showing up
in all these magazines and TV shows and
every single one of them was like hey
Gary you remember me from high school oh
my god you're so lucky I wrote back
every single one of them and said let me
just clarify one thing I'm not lucky I
worked I worked every goddamn weekend at
every holiday since I was 14 years old
so you can keep that luck [ __ ] in your
pocket
[Music]